ont d'ailleurs accompagné cet effort le
président des États-Unis d'Amérique a
manifesté quant à lui sa disponibilité
pour négocier après avoir rencontré
physiquement le président Poutine en
juin 2021 à Genève
c'est donc bien seul et de manière
délibérée que rognon un à un les
engagements pris devant la communauté
des nations le président Poutine a
choisi la guerre
cette guerre n'est pas un conflit entre
l'OTAN et l'Occident d'une part et la
Russie d'autre part comme certains
peuvent l'écrire
il n'y a pas de troupe ni de base de
l'OTAN en Ukraine ce sont des mensonges
la Russie n'est pas agressée elle est
l'agresseur
cette guerre est encore moins comme une
propagande insoutenable voudrait le
faire penser une lutte contre le nazisme
c'est un mensonge une insulte à
l'histoire de la Russie et de l'Ukraine
à la mémoire de nos aînés qui ont
combattu côte à côte contre le nazisme
les dirigeants russes s’en prennent à la
mémoire de la Shoah en Ukraine comme il
s'en prennent en Russie à la mémoire des
crimes du stalinisme
cette guerre et le fruit d'un esprit de
revanche nourri d'une lecture
révisionniste de l'histoire de l'Europe
qui voudrait la renvoyer aux heures les
plus sombres des empires des invasions
des exterminations
à cette violation flagrante de
l'intégrité du territoire et de la
souveraineté d'un pays européen la
France et l'Europe ont répondu
immédiatement unanimement
nous l'avons fait en étroite
coordination avec les Britanniques les
Canadiens les Américains les Japonais
étant d'autres pays
d'abord en soutenant le peuple craignant
par des convois humanitaires ainsi que
par la livraison de matériels et
d'équipements pour se défendre
ensuite en agissant avec les autres
nations pour que les dirigeants russes
entendent que le choix de la guerre
mettraient leur pays au bancs des
peuples et de l'histoire
une résolution a été votée au Conseil de
sécurité des Nations unies sur les
violations du droit international
commises par Moscou et cet après-midi
même
l'Assemblée générale des Nations Unies a
condamné par un vote écrasant cette
agression
la communauté internationale a ainsi
montré son unité
les équipes sportives de Russie ont été
exclues des grandes compétitions
internationales et nombre de grands
événements sportifs et culturels ont été
annulés
nous continuons et continuerons un
travail acharné afin de conduire sur
tous les continents les nations à
condamné l'invasion à exiger le cessé le
feu et le respect des opérations
humanitaires sur le sol ukrainien
nous avons pris de manière rapide et
proportionnée des sanctions à l'égard de
la Russie et de ses dirigeants
les avoir de plusieurs centaines de
personnalités russes proches du pouvoir
ont ainsi été gelés en France et à
l'étranger
plusieurs grandes banques russes ont été
exclues des systèmes de paiement
internationaux rendant impossible nombre
de transactions et entraînant la chute
du rouble
les organes de propagande russe viennent
de cesser des maîtres en Europe
je remercie aussi l'ensemble des
journalistes qui couvrent avec courage
le conflit et œuvrent ainsi à la liberté
d'information de tous les citoyens du
monde
enfin nous avons participé à l'effort
dans le cadre de l'OTAN pour protéger la
sécurité et la souveraineté de nos
alliés européens en renforçant la
présence militaire que nous avons déjà
dans les États baltes et dans la région
ainsi plusieurs centaines de soldats
français sont arrivés hier sur le sol de
la Roumanie
initiative diplomatique sanction contre
les dirigeants politiques et économiques
de la Russie soutient à la population
ukrainienne vont ainsi se poursuivre et
s'intensifier avec pour objectif
d'obtenir l'arrêt des combats
et pour autant nous ne sommes pas en
guerre contre la Russie nous savons tout
ce qui nous lie à ce grand peuple
européen qui est le peuple russe qui
attend sacrifié durant la Seconde Guerre
mondiale pour sauver l'Europe de la BIM
nous sommes aujourd'hui aux côtés de
tous les Russes qui refusant qu'une
guerre indigne soit menée en leur nom
ont l'esprit de responsabilité et le
courage de défendre la paix et qui le
font savoir en Russie et ailleurs
c'est pour cela que si j'échange
constamment avec le Président zéninsky
j'ai aussi choisi de rester en contact
et resterait en contact autant que je le
peux et autant que c'est nécessaire avec
le président Poutine
pour chercher sans relâche à le
convaincre de renoncer aux armes pour
aider autant que la France le peut dans
le cadre des pour parler en cours et
pour prévenir la contagion et
l'élargissement du conflit au temps que
nous le pouvons
les équilibres de notre continent comme
plusieurs aspects de notre quotidien
sont d'ores et déjà bouleversés par
cette guerre et connaîtront des
changements profonds dans les mois qui
viennent
notre Europe en sera bousculé j'aurai
l'occasion d'y revenir
plusieurs centaines de milliers de
réfugiés venant du crâne sont et seront
accueillis sur notre continent
la France prendra sa part
et je veux ici d'ores et déjà remercier
nos villes nos villages qui ont commencé
à se mobiliser remercier nos
associations
qui aussi œuvrent pour accueillir dans
les meilleures conditions nous nous
organisons et nous prendrons soin de
celles et ceux qui rejoignent notre sol
pour être protégé
la France prendra aussi sa part en
accueillant les enfants forcés à l'exil
séparé de leur père rester combattre et
ce en étroite collaboration avec les
associations les organisations non
gouvernementales qui œuvrent déjà sur
place et dans notre pays
notre agriculture notre industrie
nombre de secteurs économiques souffrent
et vont souffrir soit parce qu'ils
dépendent des importations de matières
premières venues de Russie ou du crâne
soit parce qu'ils exportent vers ces
pays
notre croissance aujourd'hui au plus
haut sera un encablement affecté
le renchérissement du prix du pétrole du
gaz des matières premières a et aura des
conséquences sur notre pouvoir d'achat
demain le prix du plein d'essence le
montant de la facture de chauffage le
coût de certains produits risques de
s'alourdir encore
alors face à ces conséquences
économiques et sociales je n'ai et
n'aurait qu'une boussole
vous protéger
nous épaulerons les secteurs économiques
les plus exposés en recherchant de
nouveaux fournisseurs de nouveaux
débouchés commerciaux et c'est à cette
fin que je me suis entretenu avec des
homologues américains européens moyennes
orientaux
nous apporterons des réponses adaptées
face aux perturbations des flux
commerciaux et à l'augmentation des prix
et j'ai demandé au Premier ministre
d'élaborer pour les prochains jours un
plan de résilience économique et social
pour répondre à toutes ces difficultés
mais nous nous trompons pas
ces événements n'auront pas seulement
des conséquences immédiates à la trame
de quelques semaines
ils sont le signal d'un changement
d'époque
la guerre en Europe n'appartient plus à
nos livres d'histoire ou nos livres
d'écoles elle est là sous nos yeux
la démocratie n'est plus considérée
comme un régime incontestable elle est
remise en cause sous nos yeux
notre liberté celle de nos enfants n'est
plus un acquis et les plus que jamais un
système de courage un combat de chaque
instant
à ce retour brutal du trajet dans
l'histoire nous nous devons de répondre
par des décisions historiques
notre pays amplifiera donc
l'investissement dans sa défense décidé
dès 2017 et poursuivra sa stratégie
d'indépendance et d'investissement dans
son économie sa recherche son innovation
déjà renforcé à la lumière de la
pandémie
notre Europe dans cette épreuve démontre
comme elle l'a fait ces derniers mois
une unité remarquable
elle doit désormais accepter de payer le
prix de la paix de la liberté de la
démocratie
elle doit investir davantage pour moins
dépendre des autres continents et
pouvoir décider pour elles-mêmes en
d'autres termes devenir une puissance
plus indépendante plus souveraine
puissance économique d'abord nous ne
pouvons plus dépendre des autres pour
nous nourrir nous soigner nous informer
nous financer voilà pourquoi dans le
prolongement des décisions prises au
plus fort de la pandémie avec le plan de
relance européen nous devrons promouvoir
un nouveau modèle économique fondé sur
l'indépendance et le progrès
puissance énergétique ensuite nous ne
pouvons plus dépendre des autres et
notamment du gaz russe pour nous
déplacer nous chauffer faire fonctionner
nos usines voilà pourquoi après avoir
décidé pour la France le développement
des énergies renouvelables et la
construction de nouveaux réacteurs
nucléaires je défendrai une stratégie
d'indépendance énergétique européenne
puissance de paix enfin nous ne pouvons
pas dépendre des autres pour nous
défendre que ce soit sur terre sur mer
sous la mer dans les airs dans l'espace
où le cyberespace
à cet égard notre défense européenne
doit franchir une nouvelle étape
je réunirai les 10 et 11 mars prochain à
Versailles les chefs d'État et de
gouvernement européen lors d'un sommet
qui aura décidé sur ces sujets
d'ores et déjà
notre Europe a montré unité et
détermination
elle est entrée dans une nouvelle ère
il nous faut poursuivre
mes chers compatriotes
la guerre en Ukraine marque une rupture
pour notre continent et nos générations
je sais combien elle vous inquiète
légitime
elle nous mobilise et nous imposera de
prendre des décisions
je vous en rendrai compte
cette guerre vient aussi percuter notre
vie démocratique et la campagne
électorale qui s'ouvre officiellement à
la fin de cette semaine
cette campagne permettra un débat
démocratique important pour la nation
mais qui ne nous empêchera pas de nous
réunir sur l'essentiel
je sais pouvoir compter sur vous
votre attachement à la liberté à
l'égalité
à la fraternité
à la place de la France dans le monde
je ne cesserai jamais de les défendre et
de les porter haut en votre nom
vive la république
vive la France
bonsoir à tous bienvenue dans le studio
de live du Figaro on est de vous
retrouver ce soir on va commenter
analyser décrypter ce discours vous
réagissez vous avez commencé à le faire
ce discours plus exactement cette
allocution bonsoir Guillaume roquet je
rappelle bien sûr que vous êtes
directeur de la rédaction du Figaro
Magazine on va peut-être aborder une
première question qu'est-ce que vous
retenez alors que la Marseillaise
retentit
suite à la cette allocution sur les
réseaux sociaux les plateformes de
l'Elysée d'où était retransmis cette
allocution qu'est-ce que vous retenez
Guillaume à chaud de cette intervention
qu'est ce qu'il faut en retenir
je retiens que le Président de la
République a comme intégrer cette crise
ukrainienne dans son dispositif
présidentiel à la fois dispositif passé
il nous explique que la France devra
d'autant plus à l'avenir assurer son
indépendance industrielle énergétique
militaire il nous rappelle que c'est ce
qu'il a déjà entrepris depuis le début
de son mandat et puis il nous dit je
continuerai je continuerai à vous
protéger je n'aurais qu'une boussole
dit-il vous protéger et il appelle à la
fin les Français à se réunir sur
l'essentiel en gros il dit je suis
l'homme de la situation et même s'il
n'est pas officiellement encore ce soir
candidat à la présidence de la
République c'est comme si cette crise
lui donnait l'occasion d'une forme de
continuum sans forcément passer par la
case campagne électorale comment
pardonne-moi d'arriver tout de suite à
une question mais il nous reste plus que
48 heures avant le dépôt officiel des
candidatures comment Emmanuel Macron
peut gérer cette cette séquence après
donc
cette prise de parole solennelle ce soir
je pense que il a par son intervention
et par le choix délibéré de ne pas
annoncer sa candidature ce soir il a mis
une forme de hiérarchie dans ce qui
compte à ses yeux on peut imaginer
contenu du délai très court qui nous est
qui lui est laissé qu'en fait il envoie
aux conseils constitutionnel la la le
l'information selon laquelle il est
candidat et qu'il ne mette pas
déclaration sans déclaration exactement
exactement parce que on partait du
principe que un président sortant devait
forcément se déclarer publiquement et en
passant par par la télévision ou par la
presse écrite ou
ou par un autre média mais ce n'est pas
du tout obligatoire ce qui compte c'est
la déclaration auprès du Conseil
constitutionnel et ce serait assez
cohérent s'il choisit cette option avec
ce ce que je disais au début c'est à
dire que il est tout entier consacré à
sa tâche et ma foi il y a qu'une
formalité qui s'annonce le en avril
prochain on va continuer à suivre ça
vous avez pas d'informations
particulières sur sur la forme que ça
devrait prendre non je n'en ai pas mais
c'est de l'analyse mais je me dis que
après un discours aussi important est-ce
qu'il va refaire une autre déclaration
derrière ça paraîtrait ça apparaîtrait
comme une forme de de bégaiement donc
moi je n'exclue pas qu'il n'y ait pas de
déclaration médiatique du tout on va
voir ça dans les prochaines heures on va
revenir justement sur cette allocution
alors déjà certains que je salue quand
même j'espère qu'ils sont encore là
parce qu'ils nous disent qu'ils vont
nous quitter France Europe 78 après
rester avec nous quand même pour
justement nous dire ce que vous en avez
au moins pensé cette autre
internaute dit bon courage aux
journalistes pour commenter ce message
d'un vide absolu alors est-ce que de
votre point de vue il était David absolu
peut-être une question pour orienter
votre réponse
à Guillaume avec cette observation de
Nathan qui nous dit Macron a fait du en
même temps on n'est pas en guerre mais
on va affamer les Russes alors d'abord
est-ce que c'était vide
ce qui peut donner cette impression
c'est que il n'y a pas d'annonce ce soir
du du président de la République hormis
peut-être le fait que la France mais on
s'en doutait aller prendre toute sa part
dans l'accueil de réfugiés ça
ressemblait plus à ce que ce qu'on
appelle dans les états majeurs un point
de situation et donc il a rappelé tout
ce qui était les différentes initiatives
qui avaient été prises à la fois pour
essayer de prévenir cette guerre Et
maintenant pour pour la traiter et
ensuite il y a quand même une une sorte
de de de
rappelle ou de retour plutôt du en même
temps c'est à dire qu'il dit la
croissance a forcément être affectée
mais dit-il j'ai demandé au Premier
ministre de me préparer un plan de
résilience faire un plan de résilience
il y a plus de questions de moyens
puisque l'argent tombe des arbres c'est
la France a atteint un tel niveau de
déficit aujourd'hui que on a le
sentiment que tout ce qui était règle
commune en matière de finance publique a
été oubliée alors non on n'a plus
d'argent on sait que le niveau de la
dette est au plus haut mais comme
jusqu'à présent ça ne nous coûte pas
cher puisque les taux d'intérêt restent
très raisonnables ça peut continuer
comme ça espèce de d'habitude du quoi
qu'il en coûte oui exactement c'est le
retour du du quoi qu'il en coûte alors
il y a une certaine cohérence quand même
parce que ce qui est le président de la
République avait raison quand il disait
que l'effort de défense va être continué
mais qu'il avait déjà commencé c'est pas
comme l'Allemagne qui se réveille du
jour au lendemain en disant ah bah merde
on a quasiment plus d'armée il va
falloir qu'on fasse quelque chose ou
plutôt on a une armée qui n'est pas
suffisamment opérationnelle et
suffisamment apte à se projeter sur le
champ de bataille après le bras de fer
avec le général De Villiers au début de
son quinquennat Emmanuel Macron avait
déjà fait cet effort et pour le reste
quand il dit il faut assurer notre
indépendance industrielle c'est l'objet
de de du plan d'investissement majeur
qui a été lancé
encore une une remarque assez acide
lorsque l'on a rien à dire alors il faut
le dire Macron est très bon dans ce rôle
c'est pas votre forcément votre votre
point de vue Guillaume on l'a compris
pas votre point de vue que Emmanuel
Macron n'avait rien à dire jusqu'à
présent
ils étaient nous dit la méga inflation
qui de toute façon aurait dû avoir effet
arriver c'est une bonne c'est une bonne
excuse
quand même il y avait dans ce discours
détrompez-moi mais quand même des
accents il y aura devrait être dur les
prix vont augmenter le pouvoir d'achat
va baisser
le prix du plein d'essence et il a qu'il
a qu'il a cité nommément va augmenter
oui mais c'est pour ajouter tout de
suite qu'il sera là pour nous protéger
c'est à dire que le message subliminal
et il est clair c'est de dire vous on va
vivre des périodes difficiles donc il
faut garder à la tête du pays quelqu'un
qui est expérimenté qui a déjà
affronté une tempête celle de la crise
sanitaire et et donc tout ça est
transparent il se campe comme étant
l'homme qu'il faut au pays
c'est un peu difficile de savoir si
il prévoit vraiment une un impact
économique immédiat il dit qu'il y a un
risque mais en même temps il dit on va
prendre les mesures pour le corriger on
a vu ce qui s'est passé ces derniers
temps avec notamment la mise à
contribution de DF pour éviter une
augmentation trop forte du prix énergie
vous savez la France c'est un pays qui
est quand même assez largement socialisé
donc on a même si ça nous coûte cher à
la fin des moyens de de corriger
l'impact sur l'économie salut les
internautes qui nous rejoignent
également et qui nous ont suivi sur
Youtube vous avez été nombreux merci de
nous suivre je salue notamment clos
Claudie sinon
Jean-Claude Xavier nous dit il cherche
surtout à faire peur pour rassembler les
électeurs dans la continuité d'un second
mandat
je suis pas sûr qu'il pense à faire peur
notamment quand il dit que nous ne
sommes pas en guerre avec la Russie ce
qui est une façon de recadrer à ces
sèchements son ministre de l'Économie
Bruno Le Maire qui avait expliqué je
crois que c'est sur France Info que nous
étions en guerre économique avec la
Russie avant même avant
de l'économie russe absolument et il
faut se réjouir que la France soit
revenue à des accents moins belliqueux
donc non il ne dit pas que la patrie est
en danger il dit nous sommes en train de
changer d'époque et c'est effectivement
assez juste je crois qu'il y a une prise
de conscience assez brutale que nous ne
sommes pas
assurés d'une paix perpétuelle en Europe
j'ai pas l'impression qu'il est
objectivement exploité la situation bien
sûr il se met en scène de façon
favorable notamment quand il explique il
a fait tout ce qu'il a pu pour essayer
de ramener Vladimir Poutine à la raison
la vérité c'est qu'il s'était fait un
peu balader quand même par le le
président russe mais après tout il avait
raison d'essayer cette initiative donc
ce soir de continuer oui la successeurs
de continuer il dit je suis encore en
contact avec lui pour éviter
des que la situation s'aggrave encore je
pense que ça c'est utile dans la mesure
où il y a une vraie inquiétude des
Français on sent sur
surtout les médias a commencé par ceux
du Figaro à quel point les gens sont
passionnés par ce qui se passe ce n'est
pas uniquement un goût subi pour la
géopolitique c'est aussi parce que les
gens sont inquiets en disant mais est-ce
que tout ça ça peut nous péter à la
figure qui est ce n'est pas très loin et
la Russie et l'une des principales
puissances nucléaires de cette planète
peut-être un pas de côté une parenthèse
avec vous Guillaume on a connu cette
situation de tension à l'est de l'Europe
à plusieurs reprises notamment sur la
question ukrainienne et ça fait des
années j'allais dire presque des
décennies que le Figaro explique carte à
la pluie quelle est la difficulté quel
est l'enjeu pour l'Ukraine la division
du pays
et avec de large couverture des
situations et des crises
qui ont secoué le pays notamment celle
de 2014 ça restait à l'époque une guerre
lointaine d'ailleurs à l'époque
on se rend compte que la révolution de
Maïda en 2014 qui
aboutit à la cessation de la Crimée puis
à la guerre dans l'est de l'Ukraine
intervient quelques mois avant les
attentats de Charlie avant les et puis
toute l'année terrible l'année noire des
attentats qui ont ensanglanté la France
et là on se rend compte que
il y a une partie de l'Europe qui est
terrorisée et qui est polarisé sur une
menace qui est la menace russe et une
autre partie qui est la nôtre qui est
polarisée sur une autre menace qui est
la menace islamiste la menace du Sud
certes il y a une guerre aujourd'hui
dans l'Est de l'Europe certes il y a une
agression caractérisée comme la rappeler
Emmanuel Macron mais est-ce que ce
conflit cette guerre pardon de vous
poser la question aussi brutalement et
la nôtre
oui cette guérir la nôtre parce que elle
nous oblige à reconsidérer d'abord de
notre dispositif de défense en tout cas
non pas à le reconsidérer mais à le
conforter parce que nous ne pouvons pas
avoir une armée qui soit simplement une
force apte à se déployer de façon rapide
mais limitée sur des théâtres
d'opération lointains nous pouvons
aujourd'hui
voir revenir une guerre conventionnelle
de haute intensité en Europe et le
nouveau chef d'état-major des armées le
rappelait il y a quelques mois nous ne
pouvons pas être simplement une force de
projection nous devons aussi comme comme
autant de la guerre froide avoir de de
des chars d'assaut avec des chenilles
avoir des du matériel lourd et il y aura
peut-être aussi une question d'effectif
qui se posera je pense que la réflexion
va devoir venir oui c'est notre guerre
parce que parce que c'est en Europe
c'est aussi notre guerre parce que
l'Ukraine c'est
à la porte de l'OTAN et que comme vous
le savez nous sommes membres de l'OTAN 5
de l'OTAN dit que si un des pays membres
de l'Alliance est agressé aussitôt tous
les pays doivent venir à son secours or
autour de l'Ukraine il n'y a en tout cas
du côté ouest il n'y a que des pays
membres de l'OTAN qui est en porte en
particulier à la Pologne et à la
Roumanie ou d'ailleurs il y a des
troupes françaises qui sont envoyés donc
oui ça nous concerne oui ça nous
concerne ce qui est vrai c'est que ça
nous oblige à sortir de ce de ce schéma
de que la nouvelle matrice des conflits
c'était la guerre de civilisation avec
en gros l'Occident d'un côté et
le reste du monde
souvent
antioxydants antioxydantal et et mis
sous tension par l'islamisme ben non il
y a pas que ça parce que en l'occurrence
l'Ukraine c'est le berceau de de
l'orthodoxie c'est l'un des persos
d'orthodoxie et Monsieur Poutine envoie
les supplétifs
tchétchène pour essayer de de venir à
bout de la résistance ukrainienne et des
gens qui se qui se
recommande de Mahomet donc c'est c'est
plus compliqué que ce qu'on imaginait
il y a un retour brutal du tragique
c'est ce qu'a dit Emmanuel Macron ce
soir et il annonce des investissements
de la dans la défense également dans
dans l'économie et dans l'innovation et
dans l'industrie mais quand je me trompe
il y a pas eu de mon temps il y a pas eu
de choses assez concrètes qui ont été
annoncées non c'est vrai d'ailleurs
l'élément mais en même temps il faut
dire que la France ne n'est pas
désarmé ne se réveille pas complètement
surprise par ce qui se passe je faisais
tout à l'heure la comparaison avec
l'Allemagne l'Allemagne explique elle va
faire un effort massif pour sa défense
100 milliards 200 milliards d'euros d'un
seul coup pour pour arriver de dépasser
la norme des 2% du PIB consacré à la
défense qui est supposé être la règle
dans les pays de l'OTAN et que
l'Allemagne respectait pas nous encore
une fois depuis 2017 nous avons remis du
charbon dans la locomotive militaire et
donc on peut pas dire que on avait
baissé la garde de la même façon
l'indépendance énergétique Emmanuel
Macron après avoir longtemps tergiverser
depuis plusieurs mois explique
clairement que l'avenir c'est le
nucléaire il y a eu des annonces en ce
sens de lancement de de nouveaux EPR
l'objectif étant évidemment d'assurer
notre indépendance énergétique donc là
on peut dire que le Président de la
République
dans la politique qui mène en tout cas
dans ces deux domaines là n'est pas
complètement surpris ou pris à revers
par cette crise ukrainienne d'autres
interventions au cours de cette
allocution ont concernait justement ces
questions de défense et en particulier
la défense européenne il y a une
ambition il y a un il y a un appel il y
a un vœu il y a un souhait mais
concrètement
jusqu'à présent il est pas arrivé alors
jusqu'à présent la défense européenne et
l'existait déjà et elle s'appelle le
temps puisque en fait il y a une
alliance militaire avec un commandement
intégré donc avec une coordination
extrêmement étroite entre l'efforts
est-ce qu'il faut
dissocier de
décorer les cette défense cette part
européenne de l'Alliance atlantique de
des États-Unis c'est ça la question
jusqu'à présent on disait c'est un
ancien major général de l'armée qui
disait ça j'ai oublié j'ai oublié son
nom il y a pas de défenseur européenne
parce que l'Union européenne n'a jamais
eu peur ensemble et bien désormais c'est
le cas désormais il y a cette crainte or
on sait bien que un effort d'armement
qui est toujours douloureux d'un point
de vue budgétaire il n'est lancé que si
on a peur ensemble ensuite
je pense que cette cette ce projet à mon
avis
il est pas prêt d'aboutir enfin ça fait
plus d'un demi siècles là qu'on parle de
la défense européenne alors certes on a
eu peur ensemble quand même de 1945 à
1991 oui mais en l'occurrence les
États-Unis étaient là et les Américains
ont dit nous nous occupons de tout et
surtout les l'Allemagne à l'époque avait
à la fois une volonté et une obligation
c'était la pression des alliés de ne pas
participer à cet effort de défense et
donc une défense du continent européen
dans laquelle il manque la moitié le
l'un des pays majeurs ne pouvait pas
vraiment exister aujourd'hui la
situation change alors Emmanuel Macron
nous annonce pour le 10 et 11 mars
prochain un sommet des chefs d'État et
de gouvernement consacré à la défense
européenne vous savez c'est compliqué
pour tout vous dire moi je n'y crois pas
je pense que il peut y avoir des des
alliances il faut qu'en matière de
défense l'Europe soit plus indépendante
des aux Etats-Unis pour le reste la
défense c'est par excellence
l'instrument de la souveraineté et tant
que la souveraineté repose dans la
nation c'est à dire que tant que l'Union
européenne n'est pas devenue et j'espère
que ce sera pas pour demain une
organisation fédérale et bien je ne vois
pas qui puisse avoir une défense
européenne intégrée avec un commandement
unique alors est-ce que
quand vous entendez Emmanuel Macron ce
soir vous avez pas des raisons de
craindre un petit peu un petit peu plus
autrement dit est-ce que dans ce
discours vous n'avez pas entendu quand
même des accents justement
cette volonté fédérale fédéralisante on
va dire d'Emmanuel Macron quand il parle
justement d'augmenter la puissance et la
souveraineté européenne
c'est pas la première fois Emmanuel
Macron a même effectivement popularisé
ce concept de de souveraineté européenne
ce qui à mon avis est un oxymore puisque
je vous le dis la souveraina la
souveraineté repose dans la nation
je vais prendre un exemple concret il y
a un programme commun de de d'armement
aériens entre la France et l'Allemagne
bon le la France a une avance
considérable sur sur l'Allemagne qui a
vu sur l'industrie aéronautique de
défense détruite après la guerre est-ce
que nous avons envie de de sous prétexte
d'intégration européenne de de donner
aux Allemands ce qui fait le l'un des
fleurons de l'industrie militaire
française c'est-à-dire
d'assaut aviation c'est une vraie
question je pense que c'est très beau
quand on en est dans les discours de
cette souveraineté européenne cette
défense européenne mais quand on arrive
dans les modalités concrètes est-ce que
est-ce que l'armée française qui est de
loin l'armée la plus performante
d'Europe surtout depuis le départ des
Britanniques invocations à se mettre
sous le commandement de de généraux
étrangers futile européen moi je ne
crois pas je pense que on en restera au
niveau de l'incantation comme ça a
toujours été le cas depuis le projet de
la Communauté européenne de défense
c'était dans les années 1950 ça nous
rajeunit pas quand il lit des jours de
plus en plus durs nous dit cette
internaute sur youtube il veut dire quoi
et bien je ne sais pas d'abord je me
méfie là pour le coup du discours
présidentiel quand il nous dit que rien
ne sera comme avant vous savez il nous
avait déjà
tenu des propos de même nature pendant
la crise du covid qu'est-ce qui a changé
depuis que cette crise abaissée en
intensité à part le fait qu'il faille
sortir son smartphone quand on veut
prendre un verre dans un bistrot je vois
pas trop donc
je je pense pas que quand le président
de la République dit on va vivre dans un
monde complètement différent bien sûr il
y a des réalités un outil qui change
mais honnêtement je vois pas plus que ça
est-ce que il y a un impact économique
très fort ça honnêtement on a du mal à
le dire moi il me semble et peut-être
que je me trompe c'est en tout cas ce
que je lis que l'augmentation des des
cours notamment celui de l'énergie
c'est c'est on l'a déjà vu peut-être que
ça a été anticipé après c'est vrai qu'il
y a une inconnue c'est que l'Ukraine
plus la Russie ce sont deux producteurs
majeurs de blé donc oui peut-être que
peut-être que le prix de la baguette va
augmenter mais des périodes difficiles
voilà je pense qu'on n'est pas en 1940
un autre internaute nous demande est-ce
que au bout d'un moment il va dire que
nous allons attaquer la Russie et on
peut coupler ça avec
la question de cette autre internaute
donne d'Arc qui lui dit de toute façon
l'Europe n'a pas les moyens de s'en
prendre en russe
alors je sais pas si question à l'ancien
auditeur de H&M que vous êtes écoutez je
pense que la situation de toute façon
est à des années lumières de ce de ce
scénario l'Ukraine ne fait pas partie de
l'OTAN et le président de la République
l'a rappelé au début de son intervention
ce qui était une façon de dire nous
n'avons pas vocation à intervenir
militairement il l'a dit à juste titre
ce n'est pas une guerre de l'OTAN contre
la Russie nous ne sommes pas en guerre
avec la Russie donc
non je vois pas d'intervention parce que
en plus le risque qu'on le connaît c'est
que
un affrontement majeur entre des armées
de l'OTAN et et la Russie ça pourrait
être déboucher sur un conflit nucléaire
et ça je veux croire que personne n'en
veut personne n'ose même l'imaginer on a
l'impression nous dit Xavier que
Emmanuel Macron est le seul à vouloir de
cette alliance militaire européenne
alors que nous sommes les seuls à
réellement peser
alors ce qui est vrai c'est que la
France a même si elle est devenue une
puissance moyenne économiquement à une
vocation à être une puissance
d'équilibre au niveau mondial parce que
nous sommes nous avons fait cet effort
de défense parce que nous sommes une
puissance nucléaire parce que nous avons
un siège permanent au Conseil de
sécurité de l'ONU et donc cette ambition
nous sommes les seuls à l'avoir c'est
pour ça que on est peut-être un peu plus
allant en se disant dans un dispositif
de défense européenne nous serions les
leaders naturels après les autres pays
je pense que il y a la peur aujourd'hui
qui fait que le nouveau chancelier
allemand tourne le dos à cette politique
de très grande prudence sur le plan
militaire de l'Allemagne est-ce que ça
va durer longtemps je sais pas c'est ça
coûte cher une armée et ça risque
d'avoir des débats également peut-être
en Allemagne oui bien sûr c'est
incroyable vous allez voir à quel point
cette crise ukrainienne nous fait
tourner la page de l'air Merkel on le
dit avec un effort de défense inédit
mais aussi l'Allemagne réalise à quel
point il était suicidaire de sortir du
nucléaire pour se mettre véritablement
dans à la merci des Russes et de son gaz
pour comme source d'énergie les
Allemands ont commis une erreur
historique Xavier nous dit sur le site
du Figaro l'armée française point
d'interrogation elle a elle entre tout
entière dans le stade de France alors ce
qu'on dit depuis le début de notre
discussion et de ce commentaire
Guillaume c'est que effectivement
l'armée française les budgets des armées
françaises à augmenter même
considérablement augmenté depuis le
début du quinquennat suite à la crise
avec provoquée par la démission du
général De Villiers on est passé aux
alentours de 40 milliards d'euros contre
30 autour de 32 au début du quinquennat
mais
ce que on voit c'est que vous le disiez
tout à l'heure le format de nos armées
est un format qui est plutôt conçu pour
se projeter dans des théâtres
d'opérations lointains un conflit
européen comme on le craignait pendant
la guerre froide c'est un conflit qui se
passe sur des d'abord des régions plate
et qui nécessitent énormément de
matériel énormément de de personnel
est-ce qu'aujourd'hui on a les moyens de
pour reprendre l'expression des
militaires de rapidement monter en
puissance d'augmenter considérablement
le nombre de nos matériels le nombre de
nos troupes également alors non on peut
le faire que de façon limitée à la fois
en nombre d'hommes
projetable puisque il est vrai que nous
n'avons plus les effectifs de de qui
était ceux de l'armée de la conscription
et en plus il y avait un service
militaire absolument ou donc la main
d'oeuvre était économique pour les
armées et puis
son arrêt aussi des difficultés à tenir
dans le temps
parce que nous avons des stocks qui sont
insuffisants en termes de munitions par
exemple et le les responsables
militaires ont
sonné le tirer signal d'alarme là-dessus
donc non nous sommes nous sommes
aujourd'hui incapables de nous déployer
dans un conflit européen de longue durée
de traditionnel c'est une nous n'avons
pas les ressources pour ça mais encore
une fois c'est parce que ce risque-là il
avait un peu disparu de nos radars
c'était juste pardon je vous dis juste
un mot je me souviens que lorsque
le précédent chef d'état-major donc
c'était il y a maintenant un peuple un
an c'est l'état-major des armées le
général Lecointre avait quitté son poste
il avait donné au Figaro magazines sa
dernière interview et il avait déjà
évoqué
cette possibilité de du retour d'un
risque européen
et le général De Villiers avant lui
absolument et ben voilà ça voilà qui
prouve qu'il avait raison maintenant il
va falloir effectivement que que les
actes et surtout les dépenses suivent le
constat
une tête peut-être une dernière question
Guillaume puisque comme vous l'avez
souligné au début de de votre
intervention cette allocution d'Emmanuel
Macron même si elle traitait d'un sujet
de politique étrangère et d'un sujet
éminemment tragique elle avait une visée
de politique intérieure et de d'enjamber
comme on dit maintenant cette élection
présidentielle en tous les cas de
marquer
cette d'illustrer cette stratégie de
l'enjambement est-ce que pour l'instant
une partie de des adversaires des manuel
Macron et en particulier sur sa droite
d'Éric Zemmour et de Marine Le Pen qui
sont donnés dans les sondages derrière
lui devant Valérie Pécresse souffre
de cette de cette actualité dans les
sondages est-ce que si la question
revient sur les moyens de défense sur la
montée
justement la montée en puissance des
armées
finalement c'est pas à double tranchant
pour Emmanuel Macron puisque c'est
candidats eux ont toujours plaidé pour
un renforcement des moyens militaires
c'est vrai mais Emmanuel Macron peut
répondre que il a déjà
enclenché cette augmentation des budgets
même si effectivement on ne connaît pas
ce que serait son programme pour un pour
un second candidat non je pense que
Marine Le Pen comme Eric Zemmour sont
fragilisés
d'abord parce que pas plus que d'autres
c'est vrai il l'avait vu venir ce qui se
passait il considérait que
j'allais mir Poutine était un allié en
tout cas un partenaire ils étaient dans
cette logique plutôt de de choc des
civilisations plutôt que dans un conflit
traditionnelle entre un PIB et non
démocratique qui qui envoie ses chars
vers un de ses voisins
[Musique]
là c'est vraiment le retour le retour au
20e siècle et puis il y a cette idée que
quand une période est trouble quand une
période est difficile les Français ont
un réflexe de légitimité et il se ils
font bloque autour de celui qui apparaît
comme étant la personne qui a
l'expérience qui sait gérer les crises
c'est vrai que
imaginez ce que serait une élection
présidentielle gagnée par Éric Zemmour
Marine Le Pen ce serait un saut dans
l'inconnu pour la France est-ce que les
Français voudront faire ce saut dans une
période de tension c'est c'est une vraie
question mais je pense que d'ailleurs on
le voit avec le dernier baromètre du
Figaro Magazine Emmanuel Macron profite
très très largement de cette situation
internationale découvrir dans le
prochain numéro du Figaro Magazine qui
était à découvrir
jeudi soir dans les kiosques
Xavier nous dit que une espérance de vie
pour un char qui entre sur le champ de
bataille et de 5 à 10 minutes et bien ça
sera une occasion d'en discuter avec des
cavaliers
Charles nous dit qu'il a trouvé Macron
très calme et surtout il n'a pas osé
dire que Poutine était un dictateur
comme Biden hier le président américain
jobiden a effectivement traité Vladimir
Poutine de dictateur il y a peut-être
quand même une question en ce moment là
on est dans une logique encore de
confrontation et les combats continuent
qui est
maintenant semble-t-il la prochaine
cible des des troupes russes
est-ce que il y a encore une chance
pour la diplomatie une suspension des
combats c'est à dire une équation dans
l'équation actuelle finalement que pour
reprendre l'expression de Mathieu BOC
côté on pourrait avoir un résultat
décevant mais pas humiliant je pense que
ce sera difficile
Vladimir Poutine c'est quand même
enfoncé dans une logique presque
suicidaire il a expliqué qu'il fallait
des nazifier l'Ukraine est-ce qu'on
imagine maintenant qui disent bah
finalement
non je vois que les Ukrainiens se sont
sont des gens pacifiques ou en tout cas
des démocrates je me suis trompé je
retourne chez moi figé la situation non
moi parce que la situation figée c'est
une situation qui se retourne contre les
Russes parce que ils sont dans un
territoire qui n'est pas le leur il
semble avoir quelques problèmes de
d'appui logistique et donc non à mon
avis le
je crains que pour le scénario le plus
probable ce soit celui de
l'intensification de la guerre au
contraire on continuera de suivre ça
merci beaucoup Guillaume on vous
retrouve au moins peut-être avant mais
dans ce studio vendredi soir pour pour
point de vue et pour commenter
l'actualité de la semaine auquel
commentaire auquel vous avez largement
contribué ce soir merci beaucoup et
merci aux internautes de
nous avoir suivis d'avoir réagi d'avoir
commenté essayer de prendre toutes les
questions et également vous avez été
nombreux sur sur Youtube merci beaucoup
en tous les cas de vos contributions
c'est toujours intéressant